you
[Music]
hello there it's finally here the
fortnite mares update for 2022 has
arrived and once again the changes to
the map are massive this week we have a
new Mythic an iconic zombie movie
location even more flying pois and
enough jump scares to last you a
lifetime fortnite chapter 3 season 4
week 5 let's go oh and please think
about using code adamaru for all your
Halloween purchases
so the Chrome continues to spread from
day one of the Season we've seen it
envelop huge portions of the map and
last update the Chrome pillars at the
reality tree began to expand which led
to this a stage of course and a party
like no other for the undead minions DJ
Leica is on the ones and twos and should
we fulfill the ceremonial dance we are
gifted with her werewolf abilities a
jumping slash and melee and don't worry
these spots can be found all over the
place not just the reality tree and
here's the first time I used one in game
yeah that that didn't go very well did
it those claws aren't as op as you may
expect the reality tree is now
surrounded by more than 100 Chrome step
stones with the nearby building engulfed
with chrome 2. so it may be too late to
save this poi
as it's Halloween we have a new NPC to
fight well in fact we have three first
head over to Grim Gables the house has
been updated and inside you will now
find oil spills ink stains everywhere
follow them slowly and you'll be led to
a summoning site hidden underneath the
building also an excavation to reopen
the mine shafts has begun allowing us to
venture in Old tunnels and once again it
leads you to the same ritual site on it
you will see the emblem of an octopus
it's waiting with six pyres standing in
a circle around it and should you walk
into that summoning Circle this will
happen
foreign
[Applause]
ER an ultra aggressive being that throws
fire and Rockets while screaming it
looks a bit like Chaos Agent to me or
maybe that's because of all the ink and
black goop something doesn't sit well
with me also do the circles of torches
ring any bells to you the last time we
used something like this was back in
chapter one to give our prisoner skin
flaming powers and a few days later he
created a volcano
[Music]
and once again this time the deity we
summon has flame abilities this could be
nothing but a reuse of assets or maybe
the prisoner and the Chaos Agent are
actually part of the same storyline all
along time will tell and if you read the
comic books you know that it's possible
The Prisoner is still underneath the
Island right now
[Music]
traveling over to the far west of the
island is another POI covered in that
light limiting Darkness it may seem like
someone's granny is getting in the mood
for Halloween with inflatable characters
outside spooky pumpkins and a spider on
the roof yet this place is the home of
another NPC who does not like visitors
Willow the final Reckoning character is
back complete with fire ax chasing you
around relentlessly she also has a not
so subtle interactable gravestone
outside but watch out if you go there
constant jump scares when all the
zombies join the battle as a collective
they can be a struggle to beat if you
are cornered I think Willow and The
Inquisitor need to meet so here's a call
to my Discord let's try and get these
characters to fight for the title of
Halloween NPC Champion 2022. the last
time we did that was when Shadow Midas
was here oh and uh the zombie chickens
have you seen them in game they are way
more ravenous than I was expecting and
will pick you to death whenever they get
the chance only a mother could love that
face it's quite unnerving not to mention
all the floating furniture around the
island take a look at kids TV the third
NPC is none other than Ash Williams the
main character in The Evil Dead movies
from the 80s this may be an age thing
but wow the shack you find him in to the
left of the reality tree is almost
identical to the cabin in the movies
from the cutout window to see into the
kitchen to the fruit Cellar Door under
your feet okay here's a bit of Story
Time the cabin has a recording tape on
the desk in the movie we learn about a
man and his unalive wife who is buried
in the cellar below and as it's a horror
movie She reanimates and attacks
everyone in sight if you dare go down
there you could find Henrietta but I
don't think she's there I haven't got
the courage to check yet other amazing
details include the clock which horror
fans know the young lady was drawing in
the movie and she'd lost control of her
hand and she was forced to draw this
book Instead This is the Necronomicon X
Martin are in boring English it's the
Book of the Dead and that book is also
in fortnite it's sitting on the desk
alongside the tape recorder I love this
attention to detail also Ash has a
version on his back too I was kinda
hoping this book would be indestructible
like the old Cypher PK book in chapter
two but alas one hit and it's gone Ash
is a friendly NPC who attacks all
zombies and wolves he sees and I wonder
if he could take Willow in a one-on-one
over to mod general map changes now and
the plan of no sweat Insurance continues
to baffle me it was clear in week one
the insurance company was doing the
right thing and saving our pois from the
Chrome by raising them high into the sky
then their headquarters and the
underwriter inside began to float too
even though they're building a tilted
Towers was not in trouble they ventured
over to the crossroads and now the
underwriter and his building can be
found at sleepy sound he could be simply
watching over the vertical efforts as
fish sticks Diner and Joe bar are
brought into the air and strangely the
lighthouse is no longer up here that's
because it's now at condo Canyon have
you any idea what's going on here at all
are all the pois being shook up for a
change or is something more Sinister
going on and here at condo the numb star
is trying to become the new hot spot for
Halloween buying but look at it it's
nothing compared to the Boost store in
chapter 2. that was Elite level
Halloween storage should you be worrying
about the Bromance they are still found
around the island having fun and
relaxing in my game The Fab Five were
poolside as Bill or is that Ted cooked
Burgers something important will happen
with these guys someday I was hoping for
a Halloween themed skin update like two
years ago do you remember that with the
pumpkin heads but sadly not this time
but one day my friend one day
the Flying Dutchman or the Driftwood
ship if you prefer has now moved over to
The Cove as the captain still has no
idea what's going on and the blue imp is
now over tilted Towers just like the old
i o War days back then being on the
blimp was the best spot in the game for
Easy E limbs in no builds good memories
the strange vehicle launch pads can now
be found by the Mansion near the Maze
and one over in the mushroomy POI too
and I'm still uncertain of their purpose
to be honest oh and remember last week
there was a new POI which had nothing
changed there it was just randomly added
a lone apartment building by the Rocks
well now it's got the Halloween Vibe
along with many of its neighbors too
each year this is usually the update
where gargoyles with glowing eyes and
ghosts are added but so far I cannot
find them your help is greatly
appreciated back to the story The Chrome
is almost certain to cover the entire
Island soon as this week it edges more
Inland with new locations for the
tornadoes to spawn and look at this the
Chrome nears the corpse of the Devourer
could we see it reawakened by Chrome
then nothing would be safe not thing at
all right I'm going to let Ash battle
the world thanks for your time here's a
bunch of Legends who used my code this
week many people used it to grab the
Bromance from the shop thank you very
much for supporting that I'm Adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]